it's great to see so many of you here
toward the end of the conference so
before we get started can you all raise
your hands if you're currently managing
some sort of data pipeline should be
pretty much everybody right taking some
data doing some processing moving it to
somewhere else
so of that subset how many of you are
using some sort of framework to
structure or manage your data pipelines
anybody a few what do you mind just
chatting out what your current easy no
awesome cool we should talk about that
there and compare notes great so just to
give you a little bit of context Stewart
and I work for a start-up called growth
intelligence and so a growth
intelligence we use predictive modeling
to help generate high-quality leads for
our customers and we're basically trying
to help our customers answer the
question where should I focus my
outbound sales and marketing efforts so
that I can yield the highest possible
ROI and so how we do that we track all
of the companies in the UK I'm using a
variety of different data sources we
look at sales data for our customers so
a historical dump of their CRM positive
and negative examples of companies that
they've been successful something to it
companies they haven't been successful
selling to and then we use that data to
build a predictive model to predict
basically which leads they're going to
compare for our customers so it's safe
to say that we work with a fair amount
of data and not a ton but quite a bit
and it comes from a lot of different
sources and so we have data pipelines
for taking in new data to keep our
current our set of data current we do
analytics on our existing data and we
build models I'm using that data and we
do processing and transformation on our
existing data to to do things like
indexing a subset of it into
elasticsearch which powers our API and
so as you all know the more deal the
more data that you deal with things can
get sort of messy very very fast and all
the code that you write to maintain that
data become sort of
to maintain and so in the past we used
to deal with each data pipeline on sort
of an ad-hoc individual basis so we'd
add a new data source and then we'd have
a script that would manage sort of
importing that doing some processing on
it normalizing it putting it in my
sequel and then indexing and
elasticsearch and for a while that
worked fine but as our dataset grew we
realized that we were creating script
soup which isn't as tasty as it looks on
our slide so we basically had entire
repositories with directories of scripts
that had a lot of boilerplate code in
them and it was clearly a case where we
needed to do some abstracting and some
cleanup so just to give you a sense of
how bad things got we have some examples
here
for example we would have scripts with
bespoke command-line interfaces for each
pipeline which is fine once or twice but
if you have to do that for every single
data source that you're writing the
scripts for it gets pretty unwieldy
here's an example of what a script might
look like we have processor intensive
long running tasks like loading stuff
into data frames and then doing some
processing on and dumping it into my
sequel and they're all stacked up
against one another in one big script
which is bad because if one of those
fails there's no easy way to start from
where we failed and not have to redo
some of the work that already completed
successfully some other challenges we
faced was just keeping our code modular
and well-structured especially when
different data pipelines were written by
different devs at different times when
sort of we've moved on as a group of
engineers from ways that we were
previously doing things we also had
varying levels of quality of reporting
across our different tasks so we some
have really great logging and had Airy
emails integrated others didn't and so
the list goes on and on and on but
basically was becoming a mess and so now
that you understand a little bit of the
challenge that we were facing I'm sure
it's gonna jump in and we'll swap a few
times
throughout and just tell you a little
bit about how we started to approach to
solving this problem
hi everyone yeah so villains giving you
the introduction so I guess we kind of
realized at this point we had to have
some kind of framework to standardize
this and luckily we weren't the only
people who'd have this problem and I'm
sure most of you have had this problem
as well but the Spotify team had open
source the library called Luigi a couple
of years ago so it was mostly written by
the guys there Egbert Hudson and Elias
Freda and it's now still maintained by
Spotify by our shrew honey and what I
can say is they're a really active and
responsive community that opens pull
requests so we had a pull request made
and integrated within a week kind of
thing so they're you know really on it
and feel free to go and make any pull
requests so what it does is it basically
abstracts all the way this kind of
managing batch processing jobs and so it
makes it a lot easier to write this
modular code and create dependencies
between tasks that we were talking about
so how does it do this so the cool thing
is it has this task template so a single
unit of work is called a task and that
outputs a target and then it's very easy
to kind of link all of these tasks and
targets together so you can get
dependencies between the tasks so the
great thing is is that you don't have to
think about what order you need to run
these tasks in so Luigi creates a
dependency graph at one time and it will
figure out the best way to run all of
these things together and because if
you've got a single unit of work
defining each thing if something breaks
you don't need to go back to the
beginning and start again which was kind
of a problem we had with our old tasks
so you can imagine you have a task here
which is dependent on some very
long-running job which you run once a
month and then another job which you
once a daily which is very short we kind
of had this problem where we'd end up
re running the whole pipeline just to
update this thing because we needed to
do this every day the great thing about
Luigi is it remembers that this thing's
already been done and we can just
trigger this and wait you know but it
ten times quicker than we used to other
great things so it comes with a built-in
command line interface so you don't need
to worry about writing your
passing this parameter passing that
parameter so no more boilerplate and it
can also notify you when your task falls
over so you don't need to sit there
babysitting your task all day getting
distracted when you can be doing other
things and the list goes on and on and
on and on so I would be the first to say
we're not experts in Luigi yet so we're
kind of working to migrate all of our
existing pipelines over there and we're
also creating new ones directly in there
so what we're going to do today is kind
of walk through sort of contrived
example but we're hoping that you'll all
come out of here able to go and jump
straight into Luigi on Monday morning so
what are we going to do kind of Luigi
101 we got to count the number of
companies in the UK so super simple but
it kind of breaks this down into the
kind of way that you have to think about
tasks so we define this is the kind of
Luigi task count companies and that has
an output which goes to just a text file
count text and we somehow miraculously
being given a CSV which has all of the
companies in the UK and that's going to
be our input into this task so that's
kind of high-level what task looks like
and what does it look like in Luigi code
so we have a class company count which
is basically inheriting from this Luigi
task class and what do you need to
define in order for this to work well we
need to define an output so here we're
just gonna return a local target a CSV
file and we need to define the business
logic of the task so that goes into this
run method and here this is just a bit
of pseudocode to kind of show what we
may do so we count the number of unique
entries in this company's CSV and with
the output of the task we write the
counting so there that's great
you have our first Luigi task super
simple but I hope it gives you an idea
of how you start thinking about breaking
it into business logic and output and
the inputs required to do that so that's
you know great but you have to go
manually download our company's file or
get it from somewhere and put it in the
right place which is
bit of a pain so let's kind of make it
so that that automatically happens so we
keep account companies tasks it outputs
still to count texts but now on the
left-hand side we introduce a dependency
of the count companies tasks and the
dependencies that it requires companies
downloads who have happened that's great
companies download probably goes and
grabs the file from some data server it
has an output to accompany CSV which if
you remember gets picked up by count
companies so the input into there is
count companies so that's kind of our
flow now for this more advanced tasks
what does that look like in code so it's
pretty much the same little more
complicated so this is the actual
company count art so the one that we had
before so we still outputting there
through a local target count CSV the
logic of the bond method is still pretty
much the same except this time we're
looking at self dot input so Luigi picks
up where its input should be because
it's dependent on this other task it
picks up the output from there
automatically so we don't need to hard
code in kind of file paths and someone
to be picked up that's cool
and how does Luigi know that it has to
do the company download so we have to
say requires company download and Luigi
will go away when we start running it
and work out huh has this been done yes
this has been done great I can execute
the company can't tasks so that's all
good
what does the actual download task look
like so this is the task that actually
goes and gets the file so we need an
output again now we've got a right to
the company's CSV file that's our local
target which gets picked up by the
company's count and the run method again
just some pseudocode we go and get the
download file and we stick it in
companies not CSV and what does that
look like when we run it from the
command line
super simple now we can just say Python
company flow PI give the task name we're
going to run this on the local schlep
scheduler for now we've got
talk a bit later about kind of running
this in production and what you can get
from that but this is just kind of
running locally and it's quite
informative to kind of look at the
outputs because you can kind of see how
Luigi's thinking so it says okay I know
I have to run company count so let me
see if that's been completed okay it
hasn't but I also need to run company
downloads that's also a requirement of
that so I'm going to go and check if
that's been completed neither these of
them have been so let's schedule both
company count and company download it
schedules the tasks runs company
download bump the download gets
completed now is no no's it has to one
company count one's company count
finishes up the job that's pretty cool
we've kind of chained these two tasks
together from a single kind of
command-line interface with no like hard
coding of stuff in files like oh if this
is done then do this and love above
that's pretty good what would have
happened if company downloaded already
happened
well the we'd you would have just
skipped that point it would have known
that it'll already happen by looking if
the output was present if the output was
present it will just skip that that's
how we get this kind of ability to
quickly run tasks and sort of restart
gracefully if something fails yeah so
that was kind of MVP Luigi but from
those very simple building blocks it's
actually as you can imagine quite easy
to come up with quite complicated flows
quite quickly so we're kind of just
going to give you a kind of slightly
more advanced example cool retsu so now
we have an updated account of the
companies in the UK currently but what
if we wanted to get way more awesome and
visualize the overall number of
companies in the UK and how it's changed
over time maybe in the past year so we
can actually do that pretty easily with
our current code mostly thanks to the
fact that Luigi isn't forcing us or is
enforcing all our tasks to be a single
unit of work and thus keeping things
pretty modular for us so we just really
need to add a third task like a
company's Delta and annual annual annual
company's Delta
that'll that'll call out to our previous
tasks getting the company date data for
each month in a year that we pass into
this new task and then that'll output
something useful maybe a CSV or here we
have a txt file or maybe you output a
histogram of what the change looks like
over time um so let's see what that new
task might look like so a couple of
interesting things are happening here so
first we're passing in a parameter a
year parameter and so Luigi makes it
really easy to define command-line
interfaces like Stewart was saying so
just by defining this parameter it's now
a valid command-line argument and we'll
show you example of running this from
the command line where you can pass it
in the other thing that's different here
is that we're using our requires method
of slightly more complicated in the
previous example we were just returning
a single task but now we're actually
building up for the year that we got
passed in for the year that we passed in
we're building up an array of company
count tasks we're passing in a date time
for the first day of each month in the
given year and so we can pass that array
of tasks to the requires method have a
return that array of tasks yep and so
and so then Luigi knows that the annual
company count Delta depends on all of
those tasks being completed and so it's
important to note that in order for this
to work obviously we're passing in a day
time object to the company count tests
so we'll have to add that parameter to
that to that task and it's also
important to note that we didn't define
our output and run method here like I
said you can output whatever you want
the CSV histogram and your run method is
whatever processing logic you're gonna
do to determine the Delta so just
quickly to reiterate where we're adding
the date parameter to the company count
tasks and not shown but we're gonna add
that to the company download task as
well and so now you know with just a
couple of changes to our code we can
trigger quite a few subtasks with just
running one task and that can be a
little bit hard to keep track of so
we're passing in this year parameter and
all of a sudden we're triggering 24
different subtasks that have to run
before we can successfully calculate the
come
annual Delta and so luckily so Stewart
made mention of this earlier when we ran
from the command line for the first time
using the local scheduler Luigi comes
bundled with a Luigi daemon which acts
as a central scheduler and so there's a
couple of awesome things about that I'll
talk about them in the next slide but we
should know is that the central
scheduler allows you to visualize your
tasks as they're running so let me give
you an example of that so at the top
there we've given you an example how to
start the central scheduler so it's just
a Luigi demon Luigi d stands for Luigi
demon we started in the background and
then we run our tasks same as before
except we leave off the local scheduler
flag and we add our year parameter and
we just passed that in and that's that's
all we have to do and then while that
task is running we can visit localhost
8080 - which is the default you can also
specify a port and see a visualization
of all of your tasks that are running so
you can see we spawned 24 sub tasks -
the company count tasks for each month
and then a company download task 4 for
that task the colors mean so Green is
successfully completed blue is in
progress hopefully you never see red but
you can guess what that means yeah and
so soon now that you've seen sort of
some of the bells and whistles here we
can go into one more example and talk
about how Luigi starts - it would be
really nice with integrating with other
services and tools like my sequel so we
were able to calculate that annual
company Delta which is really nice but
probably not super useful in reality in
Seward a nice case we're going to want
to store the data that we're getting
into a database so we can do some ad hoc
query so that we can use it from auto
building and things of that nature so in
order to do that we can define a new
task companies - my sequel pass in a
date go grab the latest company data for
that date and then store it in a
database so let's look at how we can
easily represent that
in code so this probably looks a little
bit different to you from the tasks that
we've shown you previously and that's
because we're not inheriting from the
sort of vanilla
Luigi task anymore we're actually
inheriting from a task that's defined in
Luigi contribu a module and that's just
one of many modules in the contribs and
Stuart is going to talk about that a
little bit later with the integrations
that are there but basically the SQL a
module stands for sequel alchemy how
many here use SQL came-- some at some
point in their workflow awesome is very
cool so the SQLite module has a task
copied a table that provides some
powerful abstractions for doing some
processing on your data and then easily
copying it into whatever sequel database
you are using so the first one is that
it assumes that your output of the task
is going to be some database table
target so instead of having to define an
output method we're just adding in some
parameters here a connection string
which is pointing at our database the
name of a table and optionally you can
define your columns
I say optionally because if you know
that your table already exists Luise you
can infer the types your column types
from from the existing table and so the
other thing that's different here is
instead of defining a run method we've
actually overridden the rows method
which is meant to return a generator of
rows that you want to insert into your
database and this is awesome
because we can put all of our processing
logic inside the rows method and then
return a generator of the rows and allow
the SQL a module to handle all the faff
involved with batch inserting into the
database I can't believe I just used
faff and presentations my new favorite
British word great so there's one last
thing to think about and that's what
happens when things go wrong I mean so
Luigi actually does a really nice job of
the Seward already mentioned you can
pick up tasks after failure so you don't
have to rerun long processing jobs but
it also has built-in air handling so you
can easily add a configuration file to
your working directory and specify air
emails or email addresses that should
receive an email with a stack trace when
something goes wrong so if you decide to
try and divide by zero I'm in any of
your tasks you will find out about it
which is great
and it's also worth noting that this
configure this is one tiny example of
all the awesome configuration options
that Luigi gives you they have sort of
an exhaustive list and the documentation
so you should check that out and see
what options are available to you there
and so Stuart's gonna just briefly
introduce some of the other options you
have for integration here yes I'm sure
all of you are probably thinking ah
that's great I can write to an SQL table
and that's all that's not true so
there's a bunch of different things you
can do with Luigi in terms of tasks so
this is a non-exhaustive list but it's
quite a few so Hadoop is lobbyist one
you can schedule SPARC tasks
elasticsearch you can create indices and
index into them you can run hive tasks
Pig tasks and all of these are in the
Luigi contrib module so we were going to
just give you a very kind of controller
to gain Hadoop example so for because of
our toy example we're going to now
assume that suddenly the number of
companies in the UK has got
exponentially bigger and we don't want
to store them in a single file so we're
going to split the input into chunks
so we create a chunks parameter Luigi
parameter and then we you can see that
we require for the company download to
have happened for all of these chunks so
we're now gonna have it's basically a
bunch of downloaded company files and we
need to go and caring from each one and
kind of reduce that down to a single
count so the other interesting thing to
notice here is we no longer sort of
output to a single simple local target
but we can output to this HDFS target so
we just say companies can't
TSV and rather than a bond method we
actually need to define a mapper and
reducer so is that question Thanks just
a just a stretch we have a mapper and
reducer and we just literally define it
on the line we create a key with a value
of 1 and then reduce it by something
over all the values so this was just a
very like quick example of how you can
create a slightly more kind of
complicated task not just kind of
running in single Python simple Python
by sort of creating a Hadoop task I mean
I guess the good thing is is that the
structure stays pretty much the same way
so you can think about your tasks in
terms of what do I need to do get them
working and then kind of build them out
into the more complicated processing
that you need to happen deviously you
would probably write a script for the
simple one go oh my god this is too slow
and then kind of end up trying to it
would take a lot longer and you wouldn't
have the modularity so in the region
limitations there are a few things which
are kind of a little annoying and this
was I think kind of down to how they
envision the the kind of library so if
you kind of look at how the crater's
talked about it they talked about it
being an API it's far more important for
them the interface and the code
structure than the actual kind of
architecture of running the tasks so it
doesn't come with any kind of built-in
triggering so you need to still have
kind of chrome tabs and stuff to kind of
kick off tasks which is maybe a little
bit annoying but I think it's kind of a
fair price to pay for the clean the
clean architecture it also doesn't
support distribution of execution so if
you've got kind of thousands of jobs
running daily on workers then that can
start to matter because the nodes get
overloaded and things kind of slow down
and go into a halt but hopefully that
won't be a blocker for most of you if
you are more interested in the kind of
architectural side of running jobs then
there was I think last week like a
library open source by Airbnb called air
flow which kind of handles a lot more of
the kind of architecting of running jobs
and so on so that may be something you
want to check out if you
if you need that kind of aspect a little
bit more I think it's probably not as
fully featured in terms of task
definition and dependencies though as as
Luigi so this is kind of if we've kind
of piqued your interest which hopefully
we have then this is kind of how you can
go onwards so there's the Luigi you eat
the docks which is okay I mean maybe
that can be your first contribution some
more examples where maybe we all try and
do that as well you can join the mailing
list they're very active really helpful
the source code is actually super
readable so if you get stuck just jump
into the source code have a look and I'm
pretty sure you'll figure it out and as
I said already the maintain is a really
helpful responsive yeah just really good
guys and that's all so contact details
there if you want to ping us any
questions and the man that tree we are
hiring so if you want to come and have a
chat to us after the please thing Thanks
do you actually put all of those into
one big Luigi springs or if not has to
find the other ones and then the second
one is where it does its dependency
analysis sauce it's already completed
from some prior run actually how does it
suit that state equation yep maybe you
sure yeah so let me try and remember all
of your questions so it's hard when
you're in front of a bunch of people so
the first one was how do you organize
your Luigi modules do you put it all in
one script or do you break it out so I
think I'm not sure if there's one right
way to do this but you can import Luigi
tasks just like you can any class so if
you're if you're saying that a certain
task requires another task you need to
import it into the namespace of your
file
so you can you can actually organize
your your Luigi code in whatever way
makes sense to you and you know in in
different files within the same
directory yeah that's that's how we do
it so we have you know like Luigi
download is you know one class in one
directory and then Luigi processor or
something or Luigi updater that type of
thing what was your second question I'm
sorry the second question was when
you've gotta toss that's already been
complete it was what it's doing yeah so
yeah that's a good question
um so yeah so how does Luigi know that a
task has been completed basically is
your is your question so there's sort of
a there's a method under the hood the
dot exists method and so it's basically
just saying your your defining for every
task some sort of output right which is
a target object and that can be a file
on disk file on a remote server like an
s3 or it can be a table in a database in
the case of it being a file on disk is
just checking to see if what's been
defined in the output method exists
literally if it exists if it does exist
it's done so that can lead to some
annoying having to sort of clean up
after yourself if you do a task and you
want to be able to rerun it again
because there's not a lot of intuition
there in terms of you know is this
actually done or does the file just
exist on this for for tasks like the SQL
a example where you're copying a table
they write another table called table
updates to the same schema and that
keeps an actual log of the tests that
it's run and it just queries that table
to check and see if the tasks combined
with any parameters that you passed in
already exists as a row in that table
and if it does then that task is done if
not it doesn't used to run it science
you guess one thing to say is you can
kind of always overwrite that exist
Smith
if you've got your own kind of logic
that you want to implement that yeah it
is possible to customize that yes oh
yeah yeah yeah sorry so that question
was is it integrated with spark yes
I don't know off the top of my head I
don't see why it shouldn't but yeah you
can you can you repeat the name of the
name of the schedule yeah so the
question was if you have some sort of
tool that can call a Python process
externally from your Luigi script can
you use that to trigger these jobs and
answer is yes
absolutely you can pretty much use
anything that yeah yeah any other
questions yes can you sorry can you yeah
can you give me an example of what
you're imagining yeah so the the
question you compose right so the
question was how do you compose a more
complex pipeline so you see are you
asking outside of creating the
dependency between the tasks you're
actually asking in terms of how the test
marks itself is done so you'd have sort
of an alternative output what's that
machine doing is very new yes yep
is not very yeah several dependency all
right yeah I mean you're kind of saying
because I guess one answer to that is
probably if you've got too complicated
branching there's probably maybe
something you can do to simplify that
kind of dependency just some extent I
think that's kind of without knowing
what the exact task is that's kind of it
maybe architected badly I guess the
other question I mean you can build
dynamic dependencies so you can say you
know if I mean we've built one there
where we kind of built it in terms of
building up a series of tasks and that
can get kind of arbitrarily complicated
but I'm not sure about the case I mean
to me it seems very odd that you have a
task which you can output to potential
targets that kind of strikes me as maybe
you should be and let without seeing the
concrete example maybe thinking about
how that can be restructured yeah I
think in in general right every task in
Stuart mentioned this earlier on is
every every task and Luigi is meant to
represent a single unit of work so if
things are getting really complex with
different branching within a task you
probably want to think about how you
could simplify things down and generate
your pipeline just using dependencies
between tasks this is beyond a certain
amount one dollar man you go to two
tiers of Supervisors okay yeah so okay
so in it so in a case like that you
could you could have any kind of logic
that you want inside of your requires
method so you know depending on some
sort of constant or some variable leave
you know establish somewhere you could
say if if greater than this returned
this type of task otherwise return this
type of task does that is that more what
you're talking about okay and can you do
a synchronous
yes you're gonna say that's a good
question I mean that's not something we
have done but I guess that asynchronous
task is going to be a dependency for
another task that's not something we
have done
I'd have yeah of course celery celery
and I know that the celery does get used
to this you know proper machine learning
and heavy lifting is that you know
obviously I look at the spark and the
goop integration they there is overlap
we'll sell the Riesling you looked and
rejected could you comment on that and
can you could you see them big using
parallel together in any same fashion
yeah let you take that I mean we do use
celery but we don't use it for kind of
job running typically we kind of use it
for sort of blocking tasks yeah I mean I
think the problem I could see from
salaries more it's not going to give you
the code structure I mean it doesn't
have the car it's not designed to run
sort of data pipelines salary right it's
a far sort of lower level library which
is there to kind of run threads
effectively so I wouldn't say that I
think we would lose a lot of the code
structure from using salary but it
wasn't something we actively looked at
for this for this task but more than
half its talk about after if you've got
ideas definitely yeah
result of that if you if you yeah in
cases so the yes yeah thanks um yeah so
in cases where many tasks require a
single task to complete so if you had
three or four different tasks that
required one specific download task
would Luigi reuse the output would have
run that down the test once or would
have run it three or four times for for
all the tasks that depend on it and the
answer is it will run it once because it
gets triggered once when it whichever of
the top tasks execute first it sees the
dependency on the download task runs the
download task writes whatever file it's
downloading to disk that file then
exists so every time it sees another
dependency it calls the exist method on
the download task sees that it exists on
disk marks it is done and then the input
is passed to the tests that depend on
does that make sense yeah